frankie montos on the mount he did face
the uh tampa bay raise on the 27th
it is struck about 97 miles an hour
so canna aboard
and here's seth brown first pitch to
brown he drills with the center
that's hit well kiermeier back here
meyer spinning around and third babies
go
wow
ronnie a little excited huh
nobody hotter that's right
fastball up at the top of the zone
problem is seth brown was
right on time
i mean dead center pose him up ronnie
talked last night about how he watched
the two previous hitters facing springs
kiramar outstanding center field of the
ball just too much on a line drive for
him to get back to make any attempt here
for the tampa bay rays it'll be tyler
glass now for the eighth time
this season right back to his place and
uh went to sleep got plenty of rest and
was ready for the day game the next day
you would be
in a better position to speak to that
than i would there's strike three call
three steals on here not going anywhere
[Applause]
three pitches picks up his second
strikeout frankie montas has done a nice
job of controlling the running game
there's not been an attempt on him
in his 31 plus innings this season
now the runner goes and the throw
is going to be in time
kiermeier went head first and he is
holding that wrist kirmeyer
going in head first is caught trying to
steal
and one more look
and maybe that's why you don't try to
steal off of that left-handed care my
went right into the leg watch this on
his way to the bag it gets stuck right
into that left knee
you're thinking that you're getting uh
you're going to be able to grasp that
bag and you've got basically your hand
sat on well kevin kermier walking back
up toward the clubhouse
[Applause]
did he go yes he did and he vacates
[Applause]
oh austin allen down the right field
line and that baby's gone
i was just gonna say i don't care if he
hits a hundred well
this proved me wrong
wow
well another fastball
down and in and double a drops the head
a thunderous blow from the lefty
made his debut wednesday night and has
hit his first major league home run
on the first pitch he saw from tyler
glass now
[Applause]
and he goes up with 98 and gets the
swing swinging miss on it
[Applause]
swing
and a miss indeed he went around so that
is the third strikeout
smack smack
i may not be at my best in the bottom of
the third but another three two here it
is
he struck him
one two
and he is out missing the breaking ball
and he overpowers him right there
second time kemp has gone out on strikes
two up two down in the fourth
two against
anaheim against los angeles there's a
strike three that gets away and the toss
down to first will completely put out
swinging
back frankie slaps his glove he's got
six strikeouts and he is pitching well
and these lead at three to nothing
oh there's a dandy strike three called
on the curve ball right there
and a swing and a miss he chases up 99
to retire the side we go to the six
three-nothing oakland
runner at third base
[Applause]
and there's a high fly ball back into
deep right field brown's gonna look up
and that baby's gonna go
home run on an 0-1 pitch
brandon lau hits his sixth home run of
the year
and the rays
are right back to within iran
3-2 ball game
and this one off montage has to feel
very good for brandon lau
and the raised dugout
with brandon wow
and that cleanup spot delivers
meadows with a double to lead it off
moved to third on the fly ball
then the home run by lau
and that is number 11. 98 a call third
strike so cannon's going to go with the
count three two two outs and he takes
off and the ball is hit
cued it's gonna make it into left field
for a base hit kemp's gonna score canada
will go to third and the a's get an
extra round
that folks is what we call a q shot
that's what we call a thing of beauty
wow
but you know the old theory is throw it
3-1 you throw it 3-2 well he did not go
hard three and two after this off three
and one there's the curve ball just off
the end of the back creating all that
english
and shooting in the left field as they
were playing him to pull
and then seth brown who blistered one
down the right field line
there's your your pull your shift
so the pitching coach kyle snyder is
going to come out three rbis for seth
brown well with two men still aboard two
men out
and it is mike zanino
there's the line drive into left that's
going to drop for a base hit
now it's a one-run game again
boys
has had some big hits and there's one
right there they stayed away from the
fastball ceno's been hunting heaters and
smoking them so thompson will face
murphy we'd all take another insurance
run the way this game is going
[Applause]
roll to the right side
fires and he threw it away
right into the raised dugout kemp will
come in to score
and it's five to three
it seemed like rosso had a little more
time
but he
maybe hurried a little bit and and
that's dangerous right there forget it
you got no chance as a pitcher to reach
back and take the ball that's thrown
especially that hard you try to lead
them that's why matt olson is so good at
doing that
drill toward left center feet and
nobody's gonna get it
murphy's gonna score alva sandras with a
rbi double six to three just a slider
spinning in the heart of the zone
and elvis with that shallow outfield
and ball four the bases are going to be
loaded
and trevina really didn't come close
phillips goes to third and rosarina to
second
and meadows now aboard it first
for yandi diaz
diaz it's a pop-up
short right field kemp backpedaling and
now coming in as brown and brown grabs
it
no feet slides outside
let me see struck him out stayed out
there
13 strikeouts for ace pitchers
dial it up
94 little arm side run
just outside of the reach of lao there's
a three on the right side only chappie
on the left side
his pitch to rundle
bounced right side
scooped up albus anderson that's the
ball game
the rays load the bases in the top of
the ninth with nobody out and they do
not score
that's a miracle worker there